[Music]
there is a stranger who comes to this
Village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry and brings
fish he comes on the king tide that was
last
night
Chu I believe that an enemy is coming
from far
away I'm looking for
warriors this
stranger others like
him I'm building an alliance to defend
us it's very important that I see this
[Music]
man Bar Allen first Wayne you said that
like it explains why there's a total
stranger sitting in the dark in my
second favorite chair
he said he'll fight with us more or
less more more or more
less probably more or less he said no he
said
no look man I don't know who you are but
whoever you're looking
for
[Music]
so you're
fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities you
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there I'm
in you are just like that yeah I
I need
friends great can I keep
[Applause]
this I heard about
you didn't think you were real I'm real
and it's
useful Arthur Curry
I hear you can talk to
[Music]
fish hello
Danny